[Música]
i
bienvenidos a este último capítulo de
elecciones 2022 un tour por franz este
programa en que analizamos los
principales temas de la campaña
electoral francesa dejamos el caribe
para partir rumbo a parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y nuestro tour por francia está de
regreso en el que fuera el punto de
partida de este maravilloso viaje la
capital francesa centro económico del
país
[Música]
cuando tienes un alquiler y tienes hijos
que alimentar no es fácil y honestamente
siento que el gobierno no está haciendo
demasiado para solucionar los obstáculos
[Música]
el hecho en francia se despertó en plena
crisis del hobbit al comienzo y es
verdad que en un momento las personas
dijeron tenemos que comprar francés
[Música]
nadie puede decir con certeza si la
crisis es parte del pasado estamos
viendo que nuestros clientes están
empezando a volver
[Música]
y
esta ciudad se vio fuertemente afectada
por la crisis económica derivada de la
pandemia y en parís como en el resto de
francia las consecuencias en la vida
cotidiana de las personas aún se sienten
en 2021 el producto interno bruto tuvo
un crecimiento espectacular de 7 por
ciento un incremento claramente mejor de
lo esperado y que compensa el retroceso
récord de 83 % en 2020 en el punto más
crítico de la crisis sanitaria este
rendimiento hace de la economía francesa
la mejora en europa
el desempleo tuvo una disminución con
casi 480 mil inscripciones menos en un
año en la agencia de empleo oficial la
población activa cuenta con 76 por
ciento de desempleados el registro más
bajo desde el 2002 estas cifras explican
en parte por las contrataciones que
quedaron pendientes por la crisis
sanitaria la reforma de desempleo la
desaparición de los contratos de
aprendizaje o la gran dimisión post
cobit que empujó a miles de personas a
cambiar de vida y dejar de ser
asalariados así el poder adquisitivo es
la principal preocupación de los
franceses este fue impactado por una
inflación de 2 9% anual en enero
impulsada por el aumento de los precios
de la energía que a su vez dispara los
costos de producción el precio de la
gasolina y de los productos alimentarios
luego de la crisis de los chalecos
amarillos el poder adquisitivo es una
apuesta crucial para los candidatos a la
presidencia
el ejecutivo por otro lado intentó
amortiguar los efectos de la inflación
con bonos de energía congelación de
precios y primas de inflación
[Música]
la crisis sanitaria y los confinamientos
sucesivos perturbaron la economía de la
capital le preguntamos a los parisinos
cómo se vieron afectadas sus vidas
personalmente la crisis me afectó
negativamente tengo cada vez menos
trabajo no tenemos suficiente trabajo y
cuando tienes un alquiler y tienes hijos
que alimentar no es fácil y honestamente
siento que el gobierno no está haciendo
demasiado para solucionarlo
[Música]
y tengo la impresión de que poco a poco
la situación se va recuperando
y que la gente quiere volver a la vida
normal a disfrutar
y es cierto que el estado ha hecho
muchas cosas para apoyar la economía el
desempleo esta calle la límite y los o
más veces
[Música]
todo lo que es cultural y económico e
incluso la salud no se habla mucho de
eso en estas elecciones presidenciales y
deberían incluso los estudiantes no
hablan lo suficiente y eso que en última
instancia la economía es el corazón de
nuestro país
un sector que se vio particularmente
impactado por la crisis fue el turismo y
la hostelería nos reunimos con isabel
adelante son directora de operaciones
del grupo de lujo al bar nos recibe en
este hotel cinco estrellas en el centro
de parís el establecimiento abrió apenas
15 días antes del primer confinamiento
en 2020
isabel plantas son este hotel recién
había abierto cuando se decretó el
primer confinamiento cuáles fueron las
consecuencias del cierre
estas consecuencias fueron bastante
drásticas y dramáticas tuvimos que poner
a nuestro personal en desempleo parcial
como es frustrante para todos estoy muy
frustrante para nosotros porque
trabajamos en este proyecto durante 5
años
5 años donde los equipos de operaciones
de trabajo de limpieza
los equipos del hotel habían montado
toda esta decoración
todo este hotel para recibir realmente
nuestros clientes con el shawaf air
france
y con toda la experiencia que se puede
tener en un hotel de lujo
es cierto que es muy frustrante no poder
acoger a esta clientela y no poder
sentir la alegría de los clientes cuando
vienen a descubrir un establecimiento
pequeño los clientes de juegan este
mismo todo el sector de la hostelería de
lujo se vio afectado como atravesaron
ustedes la tormenta no hoy me decidí a
este nuestro primer deseo fue desempeñar
un papel social nos pusimos en contacto
con los hospitales de parís y decidimos
abrir nuestras puertas a los
trabajadores sanitarios
que venían a ayudar a los hospitales
recibimos personal de enfermería de
bretaña del sur
enfermeros y médicos también
luego tuvimos que implementar muy
rápidamente un protocolo de salud
y trabajar en la certificación para que
el personal
los clientes y los ciudadanos pudieran
venir
y ser recibidos en las mejores
condiciones posibles en términos de
seguridad
y luego trabajamos mucho legalmente con
el personal
armando talleres en la digitalización de
nuestras tareas
la digitalización una tradición y
belleza
en el salario solidario y luego hicimos
muchas otras cosas como buscar la manera
de hacer descubrir las ofertas por los
clientes
que ayudas recibieron de parte del
estado
y nos hemos beneficiado de ayudas
estatales como el pago de una parte de
los salarios con el personal y estamos
con jornada reducida
esto es una zarzuela
además de reducciones en las
cotizaciones de personal
nos permitieron endeudarnos a través de
un préstamo que debemos realizar ahora a
partir del año 2022
que va a ser muy muy difícil este
reembolso se debe hacer en seis años
en la actualidad muchos grupos hoteleros
están hablando con el gobierno para que
este pago se haga en diez años
y recibimos algunas subvenciones en 2021
hoy la situación se puede decir ha
regresado a la normalidad para la
hostelería de lujo la crisis es algo del
pasado que nadie puede decir con certeza
si la crisis es parte del pasado
hugo es que estamos viendo que nuestros
clientes están empezando a volver
cuando abrimos nuestras puertas
nuevamente en septiembre de 2021
tuvimos una respuesta increíble
clientes franceses
pero también de países vecinos mucha
gente de italia de españa le baña en la
tierra y portugal- inglés
pero luego con la llegada de la variante
o micro
vimos calificada en número de reservas
en
los hoteles incluidos nuestros hoteles
mesón al bar de enero y febrero fueron
muy difíciles de cumplir
pero ahora a pesar de todo empezamos a
ver que las reservas están subiendo
junto incluso diría que hay mucha
demanda de clientes corporativos pero
también turistas
más están marzo ha sido muy bueno y
abril y mayo se esperaría mucho mejor
así que estamos bastante positivos y los
mantendremos positivos como siempre lo
hemos hecho en la suroeste de hoy ni
viviendo en cuba isabel atlanta son
nuestras gracias por esta entrevista a
france 24 gracias a wii 6
[Música]
ah
la crisis económica derivada de la
pandemia y el auge de la venta en línea
han puesto en aprietos a los llamados
comercios lo esencial es adaptarse ha
sido la consigna el reportaje de karina
ya bush
marzo de 2020
estas imágenes de las calles desiertas
en parís le dieron la vuelta al mundo la
gente se aisló y los comercios cerraron
sus puertas en francia el estado pagaba
y las quiebras se limitaron al niño dos
años y cinco olas de contagios después
en el centro de parís se espera el
regreso a la normalidad
me parece que la provincia se reactivó
muy bien parís un poco menos parís sufre
por la falta de turismo así que de todas
maneras hay un gran vacío no hay
turistas asiáticos hay algunos
americanos pero hay muy pocos turistas
de américa del sur muy pocos turistas de
hacen primera
a la mar y creador de relojes franceses
ha sobrevivido gracias a las ventas por
internet y a una nueva afición por los
productos hechos en francia la
característica de hecho en francia
surgió en medio de la crisis por covite
hubo un momento en el que las personas
pensaron vamos a empezar a comprar
productos franceses tal vez sea un buen
primer paso para el rescate de la
economía dos años después de la crisis
sanitaria sigue habiendo un 55% menos de
turistas en la capital en el barrio
madre en pleno centro de parís los
hermanos balón ver tuvieron que cambiar
su estrategia durante el cob y los
bolsos para hombres se vendieron menos
por eso aceleramos más la producción de
la gama para mujeres los turistas
representaban la mitad de su clientela
para no tener que cerrar y apostaron a
la comunicación digital la indexación y
diferentes influenciadores
le apostamos todo a eso sobre todo en el
extranjero donde han aumentado los
pedidos de adultos para interés en eeuu
y también en europa hicimos todo lo
posible para aumentar las ventas por
internet lo que salió bien y
evidentemente nos salvó la vida
hoy en día su volumen de negocios
prácticamente ha regresado al nivel que
tenía en 2019 pero el 70% de las ventas
se hacen por internet
incluso algunos habitantes del maguey
prefieren comprar los bolsos desde su
casa en vez de bajar a la tienda en
francia la epidemia de kobe 19 aceleró
una transformación que ya estaba en
curso actualmente el comercio en línea
representa alrededor del 15 por ciento
de las compras
y así llegamos al final de este último
capítulo de nuestro tour por francia en
nombre de las cuatro cadenas de france
24 francés inglés árabe y español muchas
gracias por habernos acompañado en esta
aventura